we did talk a little bit about what was
happening in the market generally in in
both sides of our business and if we
take hotels first for a second we've
certainly got off to a really good start
this year and we know that the GDP
forecast has just been up weighted to 2%
which is great for hotels that's where
they correlate and we've seen a lot of
inbound tourism we've seen the tourism
numbers up as the weaker pound is
encouraging people to come here and stay
in see our cities and our country and
we're also reckoning on a bit of
staycation as well in the UK so actually
on the hotel side which is a bigger part
of the Wipro business things are looking
pretty positive and as I say we've had a
good start to the year but what we have
been seeing and reading about in the in
the business press and doing the reports
that have been issued recently is an
idea that they'll be a bit of a
constraint in the high street coming up
and that some of the retail numbers have
started to look a bit more negative and
that people are starting to be a bit
wiser about how they think about
spending their money with a bit of
inflation in and wages in real terms
staying pretty flat so we didn't we
didn't say we were having a big issue in
our business what we said was we were
just sounding a note of caution about
whether our high streets would be as
vibrant next year as this now you've
been calling fairly recently for barista
visas are you fairly confident that the
government's going to deliver on that
what we've said as a company and as an
industry is that hospitality employs
around five million people in the UK
it's about 10% of GDP and it's in growth
so we account for about one in five new
jobs I think in the UK so we're an
important sector and at the moment for
Whitbread if I speak about our
statistics about 80 percent of our
workforce is British and about 20
percent is other European nationalities
now there are other hospitality
companies in the UK who are smaller than
us and who are more London or southeast
centric where their proportions are much
higher than ours so in the event that
there is no deal and there is no
flexible or open working arrangements
where bread will be fine but there'll be
lots of other in you know industry
hospitality companies in the industry
who would find that a real struggle to
find staff and to pay increased wages
now the share price has taken a bit of a
whack today you disappointed by that I
thought we might see a small dip today
because we've had such a run over the
last couple of weeks a really big share
price move upwards and I thought we
might have a few people taking a little
bit of profit today and it might come
down by identity three or four percent
it took a bigger hit than that and I'm
surprised because we delivered great
results for the year and we projected
another great year of trading ahead
whether we were sort of overly bearish
or a little too cautious on the outlook
I'm not sure how the Labour MP dawn
Butler libeled Koster last week she said
you don't pay any taxes have you had
words with her she made a mistake and
she did apologize very quickly and we're
not a company that holds grudges it did
give us a very good opportunity to
present our credentials we pay I think
out of the footsie hundred twenty-eight
most highest tax payers in the UK we pay
a quarter of a billion in tax if you
include rates and national insurance and
all of that goes to stimulating the
economy along with our growth of 700
million of investment and our 3,000 new
jobs a year